et j'ai eu des rapports exceptionnels
avec un ou deux animaux et je me j'ai
pensé tout à coup qu'il m'avait fait
faire des pas dans ma vie tout à fait
étonnant à l'égal d'une personne humaine
je reçois maintenant Annie dupere pour
l'apparition au seuil des chats de
hasard un récit dans lequel la
comédienne comme Hugo Baudelaire avant
elle rend un caressant hommage à nos
petits minous bref du Péret donne sa
langue à tous les chats salut Annie
Duperey alors les chats de hasard donc
le livre on le voit pendant que magie de
la télévision on le voit pendant tout
parlons c'est un extraordinaire et donc
avec couverture de l'auteur et croquer à
l'intérieur comme tout à l'heure de
l'auteur bon alors les chats de hasard
c'est c'est des chats quoi que vous avez
jamais choisi qui sont arrivés dans
votre vie j'ai appelé les chats de
hasard ceux qu'on rencontre et qui
marque une période de sa vie ou qui qui
ont vraiment un sens tout à coup qui
tombe dans votre vie au bon moment et
qui enfin en ce qui me concerne moi j'en
ai eu deux comme ça qui m'ont choisi ou
qui sont arrivés ou que j'ai trouvé et
qui ont justement eu des rapports
exceptionnels avec moi je me suis
toujours demandé si c'était justement un
hasard ou si le fait qu'ils un petit peu
destiné sur ma route on fait qu'on a eu
des rapports exceptionnels
donc on va parler de votre vie et puis
au fur et à mesure de des événements de
votre vie qui est riche en événement
d'ailleurs votre vie il faut bien le
dire prétexte il faut bien le dire et
vous parlez de vous à travers les chats
il y a un côté vous avez pas m'en
vouloir un peu mémère à son chat des
fois c'est à dire que quand même ça peut
même pas mais comme ça je vois bien sûr
ne pas l'être et en même temps il y a
votre vie en contrepoint avec toutes les
aventures qui vous sont arrivées donc
évidemment on va trouver dans on trouve
dans ce livre des choses qu'on avait vu
dans le voile noir on va y venir
Jean-Louis Barraud Jean mercure etc donc
finalement tout ça est très lié alors
premier problème votre vrai nom c'est le
grave les bienfaits de changer
le grain déjà que Jacques
à moi qui n'était pas d'ailleurs mon
vrai grand-père qui était le mari de ma
grand-mère mais dans la famille quand
même c'est un nom qui est dans la
famille bien alors Annie on le moi je
l'ai vu écrit trois façons différentes
ce soir
mais il y a un moment vous l'avez écrit
a n y ah non non on peut jamais jamais
un petit peu les c'est le seul parce
qu'après c'est Ginette alors ça faisait
comme ça ça faisait un peu exotique
Victor alors vous êtes né à Rouen 1er
chat là on y arrive un premier chat dans
un quartier qui s'appelle les
Martinville qui un quartier insalubre un
quartier qui était détruit avec des
usines de de tanage des teinturerie un
petit canal et là bizarrement d'ailleurs
au milieu de ce quartier un petit peu
insalubre on l'a dit vous avez votre
famille il y avait un petit jardin
et dans lequel il y avait beaucoup de
chats c'est vrai que j'ai été élevé avec
13 chats et que j'ai quitté j'ai quitté
ce quartier et puis j'en ai plus pendant
20 ans mais c'est vrai que j'ai eu bon
j'ai revu un petit peu ma vie et puis en
même temps j'avais envie de parler de
nous à travers le rapport avec les
animaux oui comme ça alors ce qu'il faut
dire parce que de toute façon vous
l'avez écrit donc c'est pas un secret
c'est que votre avait 30 ans était
photographe et puis un jour le 6
novembre 55 vous avez 8 ans et votre
sœur patricia a 5 mois est tragédie vos
parents meurent asphyxier dans dans la
salle de bain
c'était le chauffe-eau qui était qui
était cassé c'est ça c'est ce qu'on a
pensé mais c'était oui c'était
d'effectueux
alors vous vous êtes beaucoup
culpabilisez plus tard parce que vous
êtes resté ce matin là dans le lit vous
avez pas bougé vous êtes culpabiliser en
pensant est-ce que finalement j'aurais
pas pu les sauver tout ça vous avez créé
un bouquin qui s'appelle je vous écris
qui était les lettres que vous avez
reçues après la publications
un petit peu intoxiqué un petit peu
asphyxié c'est ça je suis peut-être un
des quand même un des un des seuls
auteurs dans la vie a été réellement
changé par ses lecteurs
de les avoir disons laissez mourir sans
intervenir ce sont mes lecteurs qui
m'ont guérisé en vous disant finalement
vous savez quand quelqu'un qui intoxiqué
à côté on peut très bien être victime
voilà c'est une merveilleuse aventure
moi votre vie est tout à fait étonnante
vous aviez souvenir vous dites une
phrase très belle vous dites j'avais
souvenir comme un
éclat d'obus c'est-à-dire comme
quelqu'un qui aurait reçu un éclat
d'obus la peau serait fermée par-dessus
alors bon vous retrouvez les photos de
votre père vous hésitez pendant un an
avant de les regarder vous écrivez ça et
alors là
quand vous écrivez ce bouquin donc le
voile noir qui a eu un succès
considérable il faut bien dire 1891
c'est là que vous avez ce choc s'appelle
missoui alors là c'est quelque chose
alors parlez-nous de ce cher très
honnêtement je vais vous dire je pensais
après le voile noir et le je vous écris
qui était la suite de cette aventure
merveilleuse avec le public je pensais
ne plus réécrire et j'ai eu moi-même la
surprise là il y a un an au printemps
dernier de tout à coup avoir envie et
c'était pour moi une merveilleuse
surprise parce que je me suis dit
peut-être toute ma démarche d'écriture
n'a été que pour vider cette chose de
deuil et tant mieux
si ça a pu aider d'autres gens mais ça
ça peut s'arrêter là j'en étais un peu
triste puisque j'ai m'écrire mais je
suis dit après tout une démarche peut
s'arrêter là on est pas obligé d'écrire
quelque chose s'il y a pas de nécessité
et puis j'ai ressenti une très douce
nécessitait une traite douce nécessité
je crois que c'était une nécessité de
vie il me semble que mon chat de hasard
là c'est la vraie fin du Voile d'Or
c'est qu'en fait cette c'est vrai qu'il
y a eu il y a eu des je crois à pas être
une mémère à chat mais j'ai eu des
rapports exceptionnels avec un ou deux
animaux et je me j'ai pensé tout à coup
qu'il m'avait fait faire des pas dans ma
vie tout à fait étonnant à l'égal d'une
personne humaine à l'égale d'une amitié
humaine donc j'ai eu envie de rendre
hommage à ça et aussi de réfléchir tout
à coup à pourquoi tout à coup on a un
animal pourquoi on en a pas pendant 20
ans pourquoi il tombe pas par hasard
dans votre vie et pourquoi tout à coup
on a des rapports avec eux qu'on ne peut
pas avoir avec les humains et mais qui
peuvent compter autant dans votre vie
qui qui est près de vous alors après
raconter ça très bien dans le livre
comme le chat est vieux un moment c'est
votre fille je crois qui qui prévoit le
deuil c'est-à-dire on devrait en prendre
un maintenant
à priori de parler de mes enfants dans
les livres et je pense que ça va ça va
s'arrêter là je vais arrêter de raconter
ma vie maintenant
extraordinaire que j'avais j'avais envie
de raconter ça comment effectivement une
enfant qui qui dès l'âge de 6 ans quand
j'étais en train d'écrire le problème
sur la mort de mes parents moi n'ayant
pas accepté du tout du tout de faire mon
deuil comment elle a fait tous les pas à
l'avance pour sa coutumée à la mort pas
la mienne mais à la mort d'un animal
qu'elle adorait elle voulait savoir
quand il mourait après elle voulait
savoir comment et après elle a décidé
qu'il mourrait sur elle ce qui s'est
passé elle a décidé qu'elle la portrait
en terre qu'elle irait
c'est dans la Creuse c'est le film de
Shero là c'est quand j'ai rendu hommage
une fille aussi parce que je
pouvais pas je imaginer qu'une enfant
est une force pareille moi je l'avais
pas eu alors bon vous parlez du rituel
de l'écriture que tous les gens qui
écrivent connaissent pour chez vous
c'est particulièrement rituel donc quel
thermos pour pas se lever pour aller
boire un café parce que c'est une
occasion d'arrêter de travailler donc le
thermos est sur la table et stylos le
cahier etc le chat qui est toujours
couché là alors vous parlez aussi de
votre vie professionnelle à travers les
chats dans dans ce bouquin parce que bon
ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'après la
mort de vos parents vous êtes TV par une
tente une période assez difficile vous
dites on avait des robes qui étaient ont
recousait les robes à l'envers quand
elles étaient usées c'est la période
c'est les femmes de la guerre et parce
qu'il y avait quand même eu la guerre 14
et la guerre de 14 de l'économie dans
dans le milieu d'où je viens moi qui
était un milieu un milieu ouvrier ou un
même milieu qui avait pas d'argent quoi
et un milieu paysan même aussi il y
avait il y avait une science de de ne
rien perdre aussi un truc très joli
enfin moi je l'ai vu faire aussi
remarquer mais
alors déjà vous avez quand même envie de
faire du spectacle parce que quand il y
a des valses de Vienne qui viennent à
Rouen vous essayez vous dansez vous
savez ça vous ouais pour 15 ans je sais
même que vous touchez au théâtre
municipal 15 francs et mon deuxième
c'était le french cancan à la Foire
Exposition de Rouen
aussi c'est là votre talents quand même
on peut on peut les noter parce que vous
êtes premier en français vous êtes déjà
une passion de la peinture c'est le
conservatoire de roi aux Beaux-Arts de
Rouen vont monter à Paris
pour beaucoup de choses
les mêmes les mêmes depuis le début
l'écriture au cinéma le théâtre la
peinture
vous venez à Paris donc en banlieue et
là à La Garenne et là vous quand j'étais
petit vous aimez bien écrire et là vous
écrivez à votre tente qui restait à
Rouen et jusqu'à ce qu'elle téléphone
vous lui écrivez puis le jour il y a
plus de téléphone bah j'ai écrit un
roman vous écrivez un roman donc on en
parlera d'ailleurs que la miroir qui est
beaucoup de succès en 76 alors au
théâtre pourquoi je vous parle de ça
parce que vous commencez au théâtre à 18
ans vous faites un film avec Godard qui
est deux ou trois choses que je sais
d'elle parce que Marina bladi était
votre votre copine vous me donnez le
vertige sur le flashback
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous avez
quand même au début commencé très bien
dans le théâtre puisqu'elle vire Popesco
vous choisit pour être la même auprès
d'elle dans la mama d'André Roussa
et puis là je sais pas pourquoi est-ce
que c'est parce que vous étiez naïf
parce que vous manquez de savoir-faire
vous vous acceptez des films qui
finalement sont vous ennuie non oh non
pas du tout pas du tout c'était de
charme de charme
très gentil non non ça ne m'a pas nuit
du tout j'ai appris pendant ce temps là
j'ai appris j'ai appris mon métier puis
il faut faire des erreurs aussi
peut-être en ce temps là on avait plus
le droit d'en faire que maintenant on
avait le temps de faire César on avait
le temps de faire des mauvaises choses
on apprend beaucoup dans les mauvaises
choses parce qu'il faut sauver sa peau
et alors toujours à cette époque où vous
décidez de revenir quand même au théâtre
à des choses un peu plus un peu plus
sérieuses que jerk à Istanbul vous
faites Hélène donc là dans la guerre de
Troie n'aura pas lieu avec jean-mercure
et là vous racontez un truc terrible
dans votre bouquin c'est qu'en Mercure
vous parle de l'élevage des des veaux
mais vous savez il y a un point commun
il y a je crois que les gens les gens
qui manient beaucoup la séduction
l'art je veux dire les idées comme comme
c'est que ces créateurs qui étaient
quand même des metteurs en scène et tout
il y a c'est là où ça m'a donné à
réfléchir quand même sur les liens qu'on
a avec les animaux c'est cela que j'ai
vu le plus sensible aux rapports simples
et avoir une véritable faim vraiment un
besoin fondamental de ce rapport je vous
assure le visage de Jean-Louis Barrault
qui est toujours un peu vous savez
comme ça quand il regardait son chien
c'était extraordinaire parce que cet œil
toujours un peu à la chinoise comme ça
devenait complètement rond il était tout
à coup complètement apaisé comme si
comme si comme si quelque chose de très
profond était en train de s'abandonner
au contact de l'animal c'est qu'on a
tous besoin de ça vous dit donc vous
parle des veaux en batterie mais ça m'a
beaucoup enfin disons c'est choquant
parce qu'on ne sait pas vraiment il dit
que c'est beau sont élevés dans le noir
avec les pâtes et quartiers c'est
terrible et que les animaux se vengent
et quand on voit ce qui se passe
maintenant effectivement
c'est pas ça qui m'a dit exactement ça
m'avait aussi beaucoup frappé il m'a dit
la souffrance se transmet dit je suis
persuadé que une torture qui est une
véritable torture quand même d'élever un
être jeune un veau je veux dire dans le
noir sans bouger juste l'empêcher de
bouger je veux dire l'empêcher de voir
la lumière et est une torture totale il
dit je suis persuadé que la souffrance
reste inscrite quelque part et quand on
mange une chair qui est imprégnée de
souffrance
il en reste quelque chose et j'étais
très impressionnée par ses propos bon
voilà alors on va parler on va terminer
sur sur les bouquins donc il y a eu
l'admiroir en 76 qui est le prix de
l'Académie française quand même pas rien
le nez de Mazarin 80 pardon un des prix
un des prix le nez de Mazarin 86 le
voile noir 91 avec je vous écris
derrière et puis aujourd'hui bah le
dernier donc les chats de hasard voilà
la boucle est bouclée vous croyez non
maintenant par contre je pense que je
non je vais écrire je vais écrire mais
je pense que je vais je vais peut-être
revenir à la fiction parce que c'est
très agréable faut dire que nous nous
comédiens c'est vrai qu'on on joue avec
soi-même avec son tempérament avec ce
qu'on pense ça à travers des personnages
un coup je me montre un coup je me
montre pas c'est toujours sur une
fiction alors comme je le fais dans mon
métier c'est vrai que c'était c'était
formidablement tentant tout à coup de
parler directement aux gens sans avoir
besoin de pouvoir tout faire comme ça
c'est formidable c'est rare je le fais
avec cœur je le dis et je suis ravie que
les gens le reçoive
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu